good morning Hank it's Friday it's
question Friday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
are there any words you still can't
spell I occasionally struggle with
occasionally also refrigerator where is
your D refrigerator did you see that
NASA tweeted Hanks video yes I did Hank
I'm glad you're not quite as obsessed
with space as you were when you were 16
because that might have made your brain
explode wait at Hanks video he said that
telescope can see into the past how can
you see into the past
okay so light travels at a speed so if
something is thirteen billion
light-years away what we see when we
look at it happened 13 billion years ago
because that's how long it took the
light to get to us
similarly our Sun is like eight light
minutes away from us so we have no idea
what is currently happening on the Sun
all of our Sun related news is at least
eight minutes old which is why the Sun
needs a Twitter Hank I wouldn't work
bummer
which part of Will Grayson Will Grayson
did you write uppercase wil aka straight
wil aka Schrodinger's will hey do y'all
fill a power steering fluid sorry that
was my question for Jiffy Lube who the
eff is Hank Hank is a comic book
superhero from the DC Universe who first
appeared in 1939 Hank is also known as
the Caped Crusader and the Hank where
should I invest a small amount of money
I recommend a broad index fund like the
Wilshire 5000 if you could live in any
period of history which would it be this
one why would anyone want to live in a
period of history other than this one
like I acknowledge that rome was
fantastic and everything but a nerd with
four days on his hands can recreate Rome
in its entirety and Minecraft what are
those blue creatures behind you there
are blue creatures behind me do they
look menacing you can't answer you're
inside the internet I'm just gonna have
to turn around and face the music
oh these were sown for me by a
nerdfighter possibly they were supposed
to be a present for Henry but anyway I
took them Peter or Gail I am with the
Baker's do you use hair product
no the puffs needs hair product like
Hank needs caffeine what's your overall
stance on the israeli-palestinian
conflict my overall stance is that both
sides need to recognize the legitimacy
of the others narrative will your zombie
novella ever be published it was
released under a Creative Commons
license so it is freely available all
over the internet link in the doobly-doo
however before you download it you are
ethically obligated to leave a comment
thanking all the people who donated
because without them this terrible
zombie
would not exist also you have to promise
to read one of my actual books link in
the doobly-doo so you don't believe that
I'm as bad a writer as my zombie novella
would indicate why do we have eyelids
I don't know blinking is for cowards
when you and Hank play clue who is mr.
green so Hank in the original British
clue to mr. green is called Reverend
green but when they brought it to
America they felt like that was
sacrilege sacrilege by the way is
another word I have trouble spelling so
they renamed to mr. green but anyway I'm
usually Colonel Mustard what English
word retains its pronunciation even
after you take away four of its five
letters q another word I have trouble
spelling this is like the John Green
spelling bee nightmare edition of
question Friday
what's your bracelet it's an Esther
bracelet you don't have an Esther
bracelet you should get one they make
the world suck list link in the
doobly-doo
why was Henry crying at the end of your
last video that is not a question that
was asked by a parent there is no Y like
pretty much the only two thoughts babies
ever have are I am ecstatically happy
and this could be better and they really
only have one strategy to take things
from this could be better - I'm
ecstatically happy which is crying why
is a bubble round because they're
minimal surface structures and spheres
have minimal surface how's your one or
two cuts not doing thank you for asking
I'm down $32 Warner Chilcott you need to
do a better job of Warner Chilcott in
sick people or else I'm never gonna get
my money back can I be your last
question almost tweeze you Hank on
Monday yes by the way Hank if you want
an awesome gold eagle shirt from our
friend the whomping willow link in the
doobly-doo